[MUSIC]
It's a pleasure sitting across from you on
stage after interning at
the Gates Foundation this past summer.
So I want to spend some time today talking
a little bit about the values and
decisions that have really shaped where
you are today.
As well as hear a, a little bit of your
thoughts around where you are going.
As well as where the Gates Foundation is
going.
>> Sounds good, I'm glad to be here.
>> Great.
So let's start off by talking about two of
the really big pillars that
have been constant in your career,
healthcare and education.
And in fact, your father was a pharmacist
and your mother was a teacher.
So, I'm interested to hear a little bit
about how,
what kinds of lessons they taught you.
And how have those lessons really shaped,
the way you've thought about your career?
>> Oh, as you all just heard, I grew up in
Reno,
Nevada, biggest little city in the world.
And although I'm a California native.
So now that I'm in Seattle by
the way I'm getting all sorts of grief
about Kaepernick.
[LAUGH] lot of trash talk up there.
But, but, but I, I feel like today and
my entire career it has been so heavily
shaped by how I was raised.
I'm one of seven kids.
And, number two of seven, and from a very
early age there was-
>> There were a couple of things that,
that I got from my parents that stay with
me today.
One is a fierce love of reading and
learning, from my mom, who was an English
teacher.
and, and a sense of the privilege it is to
be involved in health,
from my dad, who's a pharmacist.
And being able to work in my dad's
drugstore when I was young, and
seeing how my dad was so focused on people
who were suffering or sick.
And trying to make them better, made a big
impact on my wish to
see if I could do something to contribute
in medicine.
>> And you've made a lot of really
unorthodox decisions in your career.
First going to Uganda in the late 1980s to
study HIV/AIDS at
a time where not very much was known about
the disease.
And later, leaving the number one
pharmaceutical company to
go to what was a relatively new and
struggling biotech company, Genentech.
Not a lot of people would take those kinds
of risks.
So tell me a little bit about what you
were looking for at those times.
How were you weighing the benefits versus
the costs of those decisions?
>> Yeah I think it's, it, actually learned
a lot of lessons both about leadership and
about risk taking from both of those,
opportunities.
So I had been at, at UCSF for
seven years when the Rockefeller
Foundation came to UCSF.
And asked UCSF to study heterosexual
transmission of HIV.
It's hard to remember now, but at the
time.
In 1988 it AIDS was thought to
be a disease related to either being gay
or having a blood product.
And it, there was a myth then
that in fact there was this secret
homosexuality going on in Africa.
And that must have been why.
That people were too embarrassed to
confess that they were gay.
But that, that heterosexual transmission
of HIV was probably a myth.
And so, when Rockefeller came to UCSF.
UCSF asked me and my then husband,
who's an infectious disease doctor, to
move to Kampala to work in Uganda.
And, and I have a very distinctive memory
of one of my dear colleagues, Bob Cohen.
Telling me that I would ruin my apa,
academic career by moving to Uganda.
It was really good advice.
And in fact [LAUGH] it actually it, it, it
was good advice because he was right.
For two years, I didn't publish.
Uh,uh, I didn't schmooze or
interact or do things you do to become a
tenure-track faculty member.
And when we came back from Uganda which
was
a completely life changing experience in
every way.
There, there were two things stayed with
me.
One is that my academic career was over.
And I needed to leave and figure out how
to pay the rent, and, amd make a living.
And two, that I would never be the same.
And that my own expectations of myself.
All the privilege I had had my whole life.
And what I expected from myself as a
leader.
And as somebody who, who was so fortunate
to have education and
clean water and great parents and a great
family and a wonderful husband.
That I needed to give back.
And I needed to do something.
I will tell you when I became chancellor
at UCSF I called up Bob.
[LAUGH] And I said hey Bob I made it back.
[LAUGH] So I can work down all right.
[LAUGH] I just skipped that whole
associate professor thing.
[LAUGH] So, so that was that was a huge
risk it,
it especially to my burgeoning academic
career.
But a really good risk.
So that later when I was at Bristol-Myers
Squibb and I was working on Taxol.
Which was their number one cancer drug and
a terrific, new advance in chemotherapy.
I visited Genentech and that was in, in
95.
And Art Levinson was the head of R and
D and Art talked to me about Genentech's
wish to be a cancer company.
But Genentech had no marketed products
that were cancer drugs.
But they had terrific science an
incredible vision that Art had that they
would lead in cancer.
And that Genetech would transform how
people were treated who had cancer.
And I was so deeply inspired by that
vision that I thought,
well, you know, nothing may come of this,
but I want to be part of that.
And having had the experience of taking a
risk before.
And knowing that the consequences of not
taking that risk and
not seeing what might be possible wasn't
acceptable to me.
And, and so that, that career risk taking
seemed, seemed totally reasonable.
Which is probably why I'm not at UCSF
anymore, I'm at the Gates Foundation.
>> And you mentioned Art Levinson.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Who hired you.
Really helped you catapult your career as
an executive at Genentech.
Art has said that when you first got
there, you were a little bit soft.
You needed to learn how to make tough
decisions.
Do you agree with that assessment?
>> [LAUGH]
>> And if so,
how did you develop that ability.
It depends on your definition of soft.
>> Sure.
>> [LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH] So Ar, Ar, Art was my boss for
most of the 14 years I was at Genentech
and
we remained really close friends and
colleagues.
Which I think is, is one of
those special things that I hope that all
of you in your careers get to experience.
The combination of a boss who is so
inspiring and so
driven and passionate about having a
successful company.
And making a difference for patients.
And sometimes, so deeply annoying.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And, and
there were two things annoying about Art
for me that I grew to be really fond of.
One was him pushing me.
That I should be tough on, on everything.
That, that as driven as I am and as I was.
It was okay to be demanding others in
service of what we
were trying to accomplish.
That I shouldn't be embarrassed about
that, or
think that people would think that I'm, or
too tough.
And so I do think there was sorta a
toughness factor, and
not being afraid of asking people to
overachieve.
In service in what we were trying to do
that I learn from Art.
But the other thing,
and a really special thing that I push
myself to think about all the time is.
I got from Art that he really felt like I
consistently underestimated myself.
And in, in the best of ways.
He would demonstrate to me that he was
gonna keep raising the bar for
what he wanted from me or what he expected
from me.
And yet, he was completely confident I was
up to it.
Even when I wasn't.
And, as a leader and as somebody who
mentors or
manages other people, that sense that.
It, it isn't being nice to them to
underestimate them or be easy on, on them.
But to say I'll bet you're capable of more
and, and yeah, I,
I'm gonna ask you hard things, but you're
up to it.
That was a really special thing to have a
boss like that.
I'm very grateful for that.
>> What is, what do you think it's like to
work for you at this point?
So, Art was a tremendous influence.
No, I'm interested to know.
I think you, how would you, how do you
think the people who work for
you describe your leadership.
>> Gosh, I should, can I make up something
really great?
[LAUGH] And hope they'll live up to that.
Well, I'll tell you what I hope they
would, they would feel.
When I get excited about things, I'm all
in, you know.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And I'm I've been so incredibly lucky
to be involved with things
from trying to change the way cancer's
treated to creating a great university.
To literally changing the world through
our work at the foundation.
I hope that what people who I work with
would say about me is I'm fierce and
demanding and and sincere in my wish that
we make a big difference.
And what I want it to be like when I'm
leading is both fun and exhausted.
Cuz I, I honestly think it's you don't get
great things without trying hard.
And you know, this room's filled with
people who are overachievers.
I know that about you.
And so many overachievers feel like, oh my
god,
you know, I need more work-life balance.
Or I need to be easier on myself or I need
to get more sleep.
But there's something really special about
being fierce when you're
doing something important, or you wanna
create something special.
And, and, I hope that, that when I'm at my
best, I'm fierce.
>> I know you've said before carpe diem
is,
is something that you really believe in.
So it's interesting to hear how that plays
out in your leadership philosophy.
Um,you see, I think one of the interesting
things about your career is
that you've spent time both on the
commercial sector side.
And in the, the not for profit education
as well as now the philanthropic sector.
What do you think the lessons are that you
took from your time
on the corporate side to UCSF when you
went there as Chancellor.
Huge recession, budget cuts across the
state,
what were the biggest things that you were
thinking about.
And how did you take your perspective,
your very unique perspective, and
use it to make change?
>> Well, I, I think the, the, the
experience I had in
the corporate sector was helpful to me in
moving to UCSF.
And now to the Foundation in a couple of
ways.
One is, and it's something I like a lot,
about the for
profit publicly traded company world.
There's a certain orderliness, and set of
expectations that come regularly.
Once a quarter you have to tell the whole
world how you're doing.
And you have to do so with metrics that
are widely understood.
Earnings per share, sales.
If, if you're in product development,
number of approvals, product launches, do
people like your product?
Are they using them?
And I think particularly when you're in
science and when you're in the R&D world,
it can be easy to continue to push the
finish line forward.
And, and to, to put off accountability.
And so, I think first and foremost the
commercial world
resonated for me in a very high
accountability, metrics-orientated way.
And so bringing that model of high
accountability and using metrics to,
to the academic world was important to me
and served me well.
The other aspect of, of the private world
that that I brought to use at UCSF,
and already was at use at UCSF.
But I probably expanded is the wish to
have effective public,
private partnerships, and to be realistic
about them.
And I, I'll give you an example.
I, I think one of the most efficient ways
for people to lead.
Is to be really clear about what you're
asking of people and
what the outcomes are.
Too often in academia we would be
approaching private companies and
somehow, out of fear of rejection, I
think, we would be unclear.
We would be asking for charity.
Like, could you write us a check because
you care about UCSF and
we're going through a tough time?
But we would pretend it's a business deal.
And I would often talk to faculty members
about these, these public
private partnerships and push ourselves
first, but then the companies as well.
Is this a part of your business plan.
Are we part of your business plan cuz
that's called a deal?
What do you need?
What do we need?
What, what money exchanges hands?
What are the expectations?
Or do you have a charitable part of what
you're doing that you'd like to
give us a check and we'll thank you and,
and be grateful.
Those are really different things.
And the consequences of misunderstanding
the difference between a deal and
charity are high.
And so, partly because I had come from the
private sector.
Understanding what a head of R and D or
a head of a company is looking for for
their company.
And what UCSF needed and was looking for
for us as a public institution, hopefully
there'd be some marriage.
But if there wasn't, it was better not to
even start.
>> One of the more controversial proposals
that you had at UCSF.
Was potentially separating some of the
operations and
finances of the UCSF campus from the UC
system.
That didn't end up coming to fruition and
I'm curious to know,
is there anything that you learned from
putting that proposal out there and
having it in some senses fail in the way
that you didn't intend,
what could you have done differently if
anything?
I think that, that I learned a lot of
lessons for, from that one is I
think it's eh, in service of the
university being a great institution.
I I'll tell you what I feel good about.
I feel good about pushing, pushing really
hard that anything I
could do to serve the governance of UCSF
in a positive way, and
leverage all the assets that UCSF had and
has in service of being the best
institution we could possibly be for
California and for the world.
Is something I was very motivated by and
driven by,
in my quest to increase the independence
of UCSF on the governance front.
Where I think I probably, underestimated
is the passion with which the Regent's
look at the whole of the ten universities
of California as, as one.
And although I thought it was pretty low
risk for
them to take a graduate student only life
sciences, only, am I selling you?
[LAUGH].
>> [LAUGH].
>> As an experiment, one-time only, low
consequence, [LAUGH] I,
I think I underestimated two things.
One is the history and
the passion with which people care about
the unified UC system, and the other thing
is how quickly my colleagues, especially
at Berkeley, wanted to go with me.
>> [LAUGH].
>> And so me positioning this as a
one-time experiment,
only UCSF as Berkeley was kind of latching
on and, and coming along,
it kind of made it seem like a sham that
this was a one-time small experiments.
and, and so I learned a lot from that, and
I also learned about the importance
of not going so fast that you kinda hit a
wall but you know,
at the Gates Foundation, we have this
saying that we're impatient optimists.
My impatience may have gotten the best of
me [LAUGH] cuz I wanted it now, and and
my optimism probably, got the best of me,
too, in thinking that people would go
along.
On the other hand my successor Chancellor
Hawgood continues to reap
the benefits of the Regent's understanding
better the business model of UCSF.
How UCSF operates, how an academic medial
center receives funds and
the importance of being nimble in today's
world of healthcare?
And so I hope that the institution and,
and Chancellor Hawgood continue to
reap the benefits of leaning out maybe a
little ahead of my skis.
[LAUGH].
>> As a, as a Biotech Executive, eh,
really responsible for
the R&D side of things.
You really have to become very comfortable
with the risk of failure very early on,
and think about the portfolio, and how
you're gonna manage that appropriately.
How do you as a leader think about
treating failure and taking risks, and
how do you sort of, let that viewpoint
trickle down within your organization?
>> The risk of failure to me is something
that is a part of being an innovator,
I don't think you can do excellent
innovation without-
>> [COUGH]
>> Failing.
And, and-
>> [COUGH]
>> Failing serially sometimes, but, but
I think that there's, there's a couple of
ways that I thought about that and
I continue to think about that.
Think of the key part about leadership to
have an environment that accepts failure,
and welcomes failure and encourages people
to take risks.
But I mentioned before how, eh, how, how
accountability's really important to me,
and so one of things I think in, in any
venture when you
have a portfolio of projects, and I had a
portfolio of projects at Genentech and
I had a portfolio of projects at the
foundation that we oversee.
No institution fail serially and
succeed, and so what, what I would always
ask of people,
and, and especially in the clinical trials
world, so that pertains to the,
the things we're doing in global health,
but, but even more broadly.
Our job as innovators is to seek truth,
and if you're making a new product for
human beings, truth might be the that
product is neither safe, nor effective.
What the company needed us, and actually
what the world-
>> [COUGH]
>> Needs now, is clear answers that we
believe.
Sometimes the answer is no, and so the job
of people who are innovators
is to quickly and efficiently get an
answer that we believe, and so
I try to set an environment where I
rewarded, clear, efficient answers.
And I particularly awa, awarded in face of
human health,
if the answer is this is unsafe, this
isn't good for patients or
there's a better drug that somebody else
has and it's not gonna be us.
Eh, if you reward and
celebrate the people, who get to that
answer, good things happen.
If you, if you expect the answer is always
yes or
that people have projects that always
succeed, you start playing small ball?
You have small incremental progress, if
any progress at all and
if people find an answer that's a no?
They don't wanna tell you that and so part
of,
the most important part of leading an
innovative environment for
me is enabling people to seek the truth
and tell you the truth.
>> I know you've had a chance to think a
lot about seeking truth and
how to create that kind of culture within
an organization at the Gates Foundation
which you joined last May.
So it's been not quite a year yet, but a
lot has happened since then and
I'm curious, you know, now that you've had
some time under your belt,
what do you want your personal legacy at
the Gates Foundation to be as it
heads into its you know, upcoming 15th
year.
And I believe it's in its 15th year, right
now.
So what do you want your legacy to be
there?
>> Well, eh, eh, it, there's a few things
that I care about most,
Some of them are short term, but you're
asking about legacy, eh,
it's not uncommon for people to remind me
that I am the CEO
of the largest foundation in the world,
and that's interesting.
>> [LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH] big is good.
We have scale, we can make important
things happen, so in the, in, in
the simplest of ways I'd rather be known,
as the best foundation in the world.
And the foundation that,
that made a really big difference, that
made important things happen.
And, so what that means for me, it kinda
breaks down into if I
want us to move from biggest to really
that's, that's
the foundation that if I have wealth,
makes me wanna be a philanthropist.
If I can do a job that makes me wanna work
in that not for
profit sector, eh, eh, if I wanna vote a
certain way is it's to vote for
the kind of policies that enable the work
the foundation does.
All of that means that the work we do at
the foundation needs to
take our investments, which in the bigger
world, although we're
the biggest foundation are small versus
government and, and other sectors.
Especially, the private sector, that, that
our work enables that transformation we
wanna have happen and that, that that's
visible and meaningful.
And that we attract great talent because
the culture of the foundation means that,
you know, I'm, I'm on the Proctor and
Gamble board, and
it's really interesting to me that people
like Scott Cook and Meg Whitman still
talk about that early on, their first job
was at Procter and Gamble.
I want people to say, you know, during my
career, I was at the Gates Foundation,
every bit as much as Meg says, you know, I
was a Product Manager at P&G,
because that means that's a special
life-changing experience for
that person, so I wanna lead the
organization that is that organization.
>> What do you think are gonna be the
biggest challenges for
you to get to that goal which having
worked at the Gates Foundation I, I,
love, and definitely adhere to, what are
those challenges going to be and
how are you mitigating them through your
leadership?
>> Well, I think there's challenges on two
fronts, one is,
we have audacious ambitions, you know, if,
if I start running off the list it makes
me feel a little sweaty you know,
[LAUGH] it just it, it's solve polio,
tackle malaria, tuberculosis,
HIV [COUGH] African Sleeping Sickness im,
improve lives for small holder farmers.
Get 120 million more women on modern
contraception by 2020 oh, oh, and
fix the US educational system while we're
at it.
>> Okay, [INAUDIBLE].
>> [LAUGH].
>> [LAUGH] that too, ,.
So, I, I think on the impact front,
because we're tackling some of the world's
hardest problems with metrics,
we're really visibly pushing ourselves to
make a huge difference.
And so for me, being a great foundation
starts with impact and,
and that impact requires us to be great
collaborators, work with others
towards is very important, audacious goals
and so, doing that effectively means
it starts with the, the awareness we have
of our place in the world-
How can our capital service leverage,
serve as lubricant, be transformational?
What are the unique things we can do as a
foundation that others won't do?
And on the culture side, it is hitting
that sweets spot that I mentioned before,
I always felt like my best days at work
have come just in
the perfect middle of feeling really
comfortable and
free, like I can do anything and totally
terrified and being frozen.
And, and so somewhere at the Gates
Foundation I want people to feel like,
man I can make anything happen but we we
have just incredible talented people,
who should feel that way.
And it's a high wire act to pull off, what
we're trying to pull off, so
can we just hit that middle, you know,
where you're both terrified and excited.
Making a culture for really talented
people where it feels just right,-
>> [COUGH].
>> Exhilarated not overwhelming, excited,
and little terrified that kind of culture
is special and wonderful,
and takes enormous energy every single
day, to live up to that.
>> You're working with two of the most
engaged and
smartest philanthropists that there are in
the world, Bill and Melinda.
I feel I have a responsibility to ask what
so
many of the audience are, are thinking,
what's it like to work with them?
And in particular, how have you had to
adjust your leadership style in
order to work effectively with this type
of partnership?
Well, I work at a family business.
[LAUGH].
>> [LAUGH].
>> Or as other people in the foundation
world have told me, your donors are alive.
[LAUGH].
>> [LAUGH].
>> They're very alive I can tell you.
[LAUGH] Happily, eh, eh-
>> [LAUGH].
>> It, you know, it's eh, I'm not sure how
to answer your question, I, I, I
learned a very important leadership lesson
and, and we talked about Art Levinson.
And, and eh, eh, it, one of the most
important things I learned from
working with Art, who came from R&D to
being CEO.
He did not adjust his personality to
become the CEO, [NOISE] he was as goofy
and as, as nerdy as he was when he was the
head of research when he became the CEO.
And so I think great leaders, and
I know leaders that I admire show up as
himselves every day.
And so when I approached being the CEO
with Bill and Melinda, I knew they were
two extraordinary special people and I
said I'm just gonna be myself.
Uh,eh, it, and I'm gonna be myself through
the whole interview process, and
if that's embarrassing to them or if I'm
too weird or, you know, they don't like
how I operate, then they'll figure it out
during the interview process.
And they won't be surprised.
And so I had an interview with Bill that
was funny-
>> [COUGH].
>> Cuz people had told me boy when he
gets mad, you know, [NOISE] it's gonna be
bad, so
I thought well maybe I should test what
it's like if he's mad.
>> [LAUGH].
>> [LAUGH] So, so I had read something
about a criticism about the,
the foundation's focus on polio
eradication, you know,
there's a lot of other problems in the
world and
we're spending too much and so, when I was
interviewing with Bill, I said,
so what do you think about all the
criticism of the polio efforts?
I thought, well, maybe that'll get him,
you know, cuz I wanted to test what it
would be like if he was fired up.
And you know, he did react [LAUGH] and
then I realized there's a really big
difference between getting him fired up,
and being mad, and being mad at me, which
that didn't really test that well.
[LAUGH] so happily I haven't had that
experience-
>> [LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH] But, but I would say,
I am so enjoying working with Bill and
Melinda, they're very,
very different from each other, and very
complimentary, and, and
what they have in common is incredible,
almost impossible to explain generosity.
And the, the most sincere wish that their
generosity and
their foundation changes the world in
positive ways and
that's real and fundamental and the reason
I'm there.
And, and Bill's impatience, doggedness,
brilliance and, and
everything that Bill is and everything
he's brought to the world,
he's bringing to the work at the
foundation is,
is just magnificent you know, it's just a
really special, powerful thing.
And Melinda's sense of social justice, her
incredible caring for
women and girls, she's like the world's
best, most enthusiastic mom,
it brings all that to the job, and so in
any given day I get to work with.
Bill and Melinda, or Bill or Melinda, and
tap into all the power and passion and
intellect that both of them bring to the
job.
And we have to get stuff done.
And and that's their expectations.
The other thing I'm learning, which I
think is just a really important thing.
Both in a family business, but in anything
you do in life where you have co-chairs.
They're not the same.
They don't always agree.
And so one of the most important things I
can do is to point out whether coming at
something from two different places.
And it's part of, my background in science
and technology.
I think truth comes out of messiness.
And I think that's an asset I bring to the
foundation.
That if Bill and Melinda disagree, or see
things in different ways,
because of their different perspectives, I
wanna make that visible.
I'm not afraid of that.
In fact, I embrace that.
Because my fundamental belief as a leader
is, the more disparate voices, for
me a big part of diversity and why I like
diversity.
Is the more different views that come from
very different places,
really good outcomes will happen.
We'll get a, a better answer, or the best
answer, from that.
So I'm trying to tap into that part of me,
and that affinity I have for
differences to be a good partner for the
two of them.
>> I think one more question before we
turn it over to the audience for Q and A.
But, you have been able to balance that
delicate intersection between
having a successful career and also having
a life of meaning.
And that's a question I think a lot of us
in the audience are trying to
wrestle with right now is, how do we have
both of those things?
What advice do you have to share with us
about how we can think about our
careers going forward?
>> Oh, it's it, it, one of the aspects of
my life that we
haven't talked about that's the most
special to me is, I'm a cancer doctor.
So as a cancer doctor, you interact with
people in a really special way.
And that is often you have to tell people
that they're gonna die,
faster than you hope, and faster than they
would wish for themselves.
And I think in the, in the worst ways, and
the worst days that made me feel like a
failure.
Like I just couldn't fix things that I
wanted to fix.
And the best outcome of that for
me was what you talked about before my own
sense of carpe diem.
You know, every day's precious.
Every week is a great week that I get to
have.
And so, I just really believe in having
fun.
If I'm in the middle of something hard, if
I'm working, if I'm not at work,
I want everything I experience to be
meaningful and special.
And I've not always been great at
work-life balance, but
I'm really good at having fun.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I don't believe in suffering.
It just is overrated.
And I often tell people and in this, in
academia I can you guys,
no dismissal of academia, but this thing
of being the most pitiful.
I told faculty members, do not come in my
office and claim to be the most pitiful.
I'm not giving an award for that.
You know, I don't believe in it.
So, for me, and everybody's different, for
me, making sure that I have fun.
That I get to enjoy my colleagues at work.
I spend a lot of time at work.
I should enjoy my colleagues.
I should find out what about them is
interesting.
That I can learn from and I can enjoy.
I really like sports.
I really enjoy being with my husband.
And I like my family and spend time with
my family.
But just deciding that life's gonna be
fun.
And that if there's every a week or
a month where it's not, that it starts
with me making sure it is.
And I tell my colleagues at the Gates
Foundation, cuz we're all into it and
we over-do.
We are serial over-doers.
It's self manage.
Nobody's gonna understand as well as you
do how much sleep you need,
how much fun you need, how much exercise
you need.
What you should eat, who you should
surround yourself with.
So manage yourself so that you can be
happy.
And I think if there's any one thing that
I've tried to do, and
I'm not always successful in doing it.
Is to manage myself, so that I enjoy life,
and I can show up better if I do that.
And that's been really good self-advice,
and I'm trying to take it.
>> [LAUGH].
>> Well, thank you, Sue.
So, we're going to now, turn things over
to the audience for Q and A.
We've got some mics that are gonna be
passed around on this first level.
If you could raise your hand and keep your
hand raised.
Once you get the mic please stand up and
share your name and
affiliation before stating your question.
We also, have, hashtag that
you can use in order to tweet your
questions, which we'll also be taking.
That's a good option for those of you who
are in the balcony.
So that hashtag is #GSBBFTT.
And we'll start with a question over here,
please.
>> Well, thank you so much.
Marcello Palazzi, I'm a DCI Fellow here
and
founder of the B Corp, which is a group of
progressive companies around the world.
We're big fans of your foundation.
Actually, one of the foundation I'm
involved,
Talbot Foundation, gave an award to
Melinda Foundation last year.
So well, I have a question.
We in Europe, we see your foundation as a
kinda model of what, a U.S.
foundation can be.
And sometimes, the question is, you seem
to be very focused on health, and
that, and health.
And given that many of the challenges in
the world are systemic,
we just wonder whether you have
discussion, you have discussion about.
This sorta dilemma being too focused
versus being more of a generalist.
Because actually that's too traditional in
many U.S. foundations.
Thank you.
>> Thanks for the questions, so, so
the foundation has, has a focus on global
health, global development.
That includes agriculture, financial
services for the poor,.
Some of the areas that are broader beyond
health, and in the U.S.
our primary focus is on U.S. education.
The foundation is always asking ourselves
about the scope of our work, and
where we spend our time and energy and our
funds.
And we often have small projects that are
going on to access whether we
should go into other areas and, and more
broad.
One of the really positive aspects about
the focus on global health as an example.
And I think why the Gates Foundation
originally went down that
road is it's really clear what the global
burden of disease is.
And one can make very crisp decisions to
use global burden of disease as
your metric for what you're gonna tackle.
There's a clarity of that.
And a really clear purpose of doing that.
So that we can have metrics both for
success and about what we tackle.
And when we look in some other areas,
we always ask does the foundation have a
unique opportunity to contribute?
And will we be able to measure and know if
our efforts are making a difference?
Some of the most important things we're
asked about don't have those
attributes that are as easy to track or
measure.
And yet, we continue to push ourselves to
ask that question.
We have a question from Twitter?
>> Yep this is from first year MBA Daniel
Burroughs.
He you say the Gates Foundation in the
world, but
is it big enough for objectives?
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> Yes, if.
So we're big enough to meet our
objectives.
If we think of our funds and our resources
which include
the people's time and energy at the
foundation as leverage.
And so, it's not uncommon for the
foundation to be involved in an effort.
the, Global Alliance For Vaccines
Initiative is a good example.
That are going to raise more than $7
billion to bring vaccines to
the world's poorest people.
That involves a global effort on global
vaccination.
On low price accessible vaccines.
Our efforts are magnified by the leverage
we get when others come in.
So I think our ambitions are not too
large.
If we think of our efforts as bringing
others in and
the leverage you get from the foundations
investments.
>> I'm sorry, do you have the mic?
>> Hi, my name's Austin.
I had a question that kinda of
piggybacking off the,
the response you gave to the first
question.
When you said that there are a lot of
issues that are very difficult to
measure outcomes for.
And you're grappling with, kinda how to
address that.
I was curious as to your thoughts on, do
you think that all beneficial or
positive outcomes that you're looking for
are eventually measurable?
And if not, how do you think about making
change in arenas where
the outcome we're looking for may never be
fully and accurately measured?
>> That's, it, it, the direct answer to
your question is no.
I think there are important things we care
about and
should care about that can't be measured.
And that, that brings a dilemma.
It is one of the things that I think is
important to recognize if you're in
a not for profit world is you have to do
better than good intentions.
Right?
So good intentions don't change the world,
by themselves.
So I would be open to thinking about
something that can't have really clear,
measurable outcomes.
Like number of kids vaccinated, number of,
of people who's lives were saved because
they didn't get measles, for example.
Those are really.
You know as a physician, I, I got that.
Right?
Poverty.
Poverty's measurable, how much money a
family has,
poverty's a measurable outcome.
If you start to focus on poverty, you have
to look long term.
But there are some metrics that can be
associated with that.
Social justice is another thing that can
start to get into things.
How do you know that you've got social
justice?
What would be most important to me is that
there's some way to
know your investments are moving some
needle.
So I think that there,
there are maybe metrics that could be used
that can start to get at it.
And get a sense for if you're changing
outcomes that you care about.
but, but
what would make me unhappy is if we got
into an area where we really had no clue.
I just don't see us doing that.
Because the chance to fritter away capital
that could be used on something where we
can measure outcomes, would just be too
high.
>> Do we have a question from this side?
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> In speaking with, your predecessor of
the Gates Foundation, Jeff Raikes.
He mentioned a wide variety of people who
work in, in the foundation worlds.
Sorta nonprofit types or who are
passionate about social justice,
academics, who want to learn how to
measure impact.
You know, with a lot of precision and
private sector types who kinda just wanna
get things done.
And all, all three of those types seems to
be part of your career background.
So I guess my question is, you know,
what do you think you bring most to your
job leading the foundation?
And do you think the balance is right?
Do you think that those disparate voices
are leading to truth?
Or are you trying to steer the foundation
in,
in one of those directions more than the
others?
>> I, I think it's great to have people
involved in the foundation world who
come from a variety of backgrounds and
sectors.
I think that's helpful and, and healthy.
what, I, I, and I do think the mix
generates good outcomes.
what, what I would focus on is,
is a couple of things that I think need to
be balanced.
What we've seen in the philanthropic world
is a lot of people who've
been successful in the private sector come
into the not-for-profit world.
And there's been a little bit of a culture
clash.
And that's why I say this, this question
of, we know good when we see it,
and good intentions.
Have been sorta traditional in the
not-for-profit sector.
Or were under funded and under salaried
and under a lot of things, so
don't expect too much.
That it can feel like that in the
not-for-profit sector.
And so, I think bringing accountability,
resources, talent.
Upping the ante is a really healthy thing.
On the other hand I think it's a valid
criticism of a lot of
newcomers to philanthropy.
And I put myself on that list, that we can
bring a certain naivete.
And the naivete is bringing western
solutions, or
a western way of thinking, or a very techy
way of thinking.
To problems that would be solved if we
actually sat down with the woman in
the village, and she could tell you why
she can't get water.
Because of something simple that you tried
to fix with a complex solution.
And so, I think that the, the, the
combination of bringing the,
those resources, that talent, that
passion, that accountability.
With, with the humility to understand that
on the ground in a different culture,
you really don't know.
And everything's a collaboration.
I think that combination can generate
something that can be very positive.
That and the last thing I'll say on that
is the as impatient as I am.
I do think the most important great
philanthropic outcomes are measured in
years not months.
>> Thank you.
I'll take a question from Twitter but
I also want to say, please make sure to
state your name and
affiliation when we call on you.
>> So this is from Sharon.
She wants to know, you, you mentioned in
the beginning about ways to
motivate people and get them to provide
clear answers and take risks.
What kinda behaviors don't you reward?
Or, or do you discourage?
>> Oh.
[LAUGH] I'm trying to, I'm trying to,
to, to give a short a short answer.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Some of my least favorite probably my
very least favorite is, it wasn't me.
That guy's the reason that failed.
If not for him or his function or
his people, we'd be in a different and
better place.
That's a really high on my list of, of an
answer not to give.
the, the other one is, is that we work
with a partner, and,
you know, they saw it this way and that's
because they're stupid.
Not because they disagreed with us, or
they come at from a different point of
view, or have a different experience.
Is it to, to underestimate either a
partner or a different function.
I love team work and, and
one of the great things I was thrown into
when I worked at Bristol-Myers Squibb,
is I got on a team when I worked on Taxol
with Manufacturing, and Sales, and
Regulatory and, and all these people who
had no idea what they did.
But I came really quickly to understand
none of the great stuff I wanted to
have happen would happen without them.
And so the fact that I didn't know what
Sales and
Marketing did was me being ignorant not
them having value.
[LAUGH] And, and I think that's, that's
the very important thing, particularly for
technical people, scientists, physicians,
is not to over estimate the fact that
because you know science, or IT, or
something that you, that extends into
knowing everything.
So that would be on the list too [LAUGH].
>> [LAUGH] Do we have a question from
[INAUDIBLE]?
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> Hi, I'm Roz Naylor.
I direct the Center on Food Security and
the Environment at Stanford and
a professor of Environmental Earth System
and Science.
I really enjoyed the interview on both
your parts, it's really wonderful.
I had a questions about coming into a
large organization where you
have an incredible Global Health Program,
Agricultural Development Program,
Education Program.
And at one level you've got such talented
people you want to
just give the best incentives and let
those divisions really take off.
Yet at the intersection of those different
divisions might be
the most creative solutions.
For example, a number of the global health
issues may really be dependent on
much better nutrition, or the ending of
malnutrition in those areas.
similarly, the best advances in
agricultural development may be
the solving of some of the productivity
depleting disease issues.
How do you motivate really good creativity
and productivity at the intersections
when, when you really need some
disciplinary strength as well?
>> That is so hard to do.
I can tell you that the, it's one of the
biggest challenges.
I'll give you two ways that I've started
to think about this.
One is geography.
So, w, we can take advantage of the fact
that we have multiple programs going on in
certain geographies, like Northern India,
like Ethiopia.
And we have what's called a tech panel,
where we bring together in the geography,
all of, the various silos in the
foundation,
who are working on different aspects of
problems.
So it may be nutrition, family planning
vaccination and agriculture.
But all being done in Ethiopia.
So bringing together those folks so that
they know what each other are doing.
And coordinate through our country offices
and
through that geography can start to help
us connect those dots and look across.
The other thing that I'm trying to do at
the foundation is
have a very strong executive leadership
team.
If we can't expect people in the trenches
to collaborate,
if the executive leadership team isn't
collaborating, and
I think in the foundation, our foundation,
we've expected the executive
leadership team to focus a lot of business
process and less on strategy.
I'm trying to turn that on its head, and
have a much more strategic focus on
the executive leadership team and look at
those intersections.
Including the executive leadership team
showing up in pairs, in geographies, and
at the foundation, so we can start
connecting at our level.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> Oh, we'll take this question little.
>> Good afternoon I'm an MBA1 student to
continue somewhat with
Professor Nailer's question.
How do you balance the funding the funding
of
new technology versus the implementation
of a specific technology on a sector?
And then assuming that, that varies by, by
sector does this have implications for
how businesses should consider
opportunities?
>> There's, there's not a neat and tidy
answer to your question.
So, so, I, I, I will tell you that the the
way I
start to think about this is there are
times when delivery as you
call it there sort of making existing
tools reach where they need to reach.
Makes good sense.
Often at scale, that's the job of the
Ministry of Health for example or
the Ministry of Agriculture.
So, so for me the delivery aspect of what
we do has to be very clear,
often involving innovation, or a pilot, or
trying to do something that then can be
scaled.
Because we're never gonna deliver on a
global basis.
that's, that's for others to do that.
So we have to be extremely purposeful with
our delivery methods, and, and
be thoughtful about what that looks like,
and how we make that real.
So that often involves delivery
innovation.
So really important that delivery
innovation is a part of what we do.
On the technology side we, we have an
affinity, and
I have an affinity for technology
solutions.
But I look at technology solutions through
a really clear lens.
And that is, is, will this really change
things?
So I was involved in a discussion
yesterday about cervical cancer.
Screening for cervical cancer and
preventing cervical cancer is really hard
at scale.
It involves women who are 35 to 50,
a little older than typical use the health
care system in a low resource country.
And you have to see many, many women
before you can truly prevent cancer.
So, if we had a diagnostic that looks at
Oncogenic Papillovi, Papilloma Virus.
If, if we had something that really was,
was transformative in
saying all these women don't need this
expensive hard to execute screening.
That would be a transformative diagnostic.
That's the kind of thing I wanna find.
So often the best discussions I'm involved
in talk about delivery,
talk about a missing technology and the
likelihood that we
can provide something that transforms that
delivery, that the ministry,
government, others are providing because
everything's easier after that.
That's where I think we're at our finest.
>> Given the limited time remaining I want
to conclude with a question, Sue,
that is near and dear to many of us in the
audience.
What matters most to you and why?
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> What matters most to me is that the,
as a leader I can allow for really
talented people
to do things that improve people's chance
at a happy life.
The reason for me is, and it kinda gets
back to how I was raised and
the environment I was in.
Just, I became a physician because I
really wanted, and want to think that,
you know, to, to the, The Gates Foundation
motto is all lives have equal value.
So that everybody has a chance to be
healthy and happy and
have a, the life they'd like for
themselves and their families.
And so thinking about how you know, when I
was a doctor and interacted with a patient
one at a time, I cared so deeply that that
patient would have a good experience.
And when I left the general practice of
medicine and moved as a leader.
My hope is that many more patients and
many more people.
>> [COUGH].
>> Will have a chance to have the kind of
life I hope for them.
And that the really talented people I get
to work with are inspired and
have that passion and oomph and drive to
create those things, and that I helped.
>> Well thank you so much for your
insights and your candor.
And we can't wait to see how you continue
to improve the world.
So thank you so much, Sue.
[APPLAUSE].
[MUSIC]